So there is so much career advice for
women.
Best career advice that you are not
getting is to invest.
What?
That has absolutely nothing to do with
my performance.
The job,
yes,
but it does have to do with having more
money.
And if you are investing to the same
extent that the guys are that will on
average and has historically added to
your wealth,
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
some women,
millions of dollars over the course of
their lives.
What happens when you've got more money?
You can play looser,
right?
You can with more confidence.
Go in and ask for that promotion for
that overseas assignment.
Quit that job.
You cannot stand because that boss is
such a jerk.
Start Your own business.
You know,
test your own business.
The degrees of freedom,
when we've got more money are
substantial.
And I'll even take it,
you know,
all the way to also help us get to
equality with men.
That confidence in the workforce,
that equality ladies,
we will not be equal with men until
we're financially equal with men.
So the best career advice you're not
getting is to invest.
I wish I didn't have to give you this
advice that I wish every company out
there just let you be you,
you know,
and that you're just not comfortable
going in and negotiating for the raise
and not to force you to do it,
to pay close that gender pay gap,
pay everybody exactly what they're worth
and not make negotiating a core part of
getting compensated in this country.
So I wish I didn't have to do that.
Um,
but I do.
And so we have to accept the world as it
is today.
And so ladies,
you got to negotiate from the first job.
You just have to,
and let me give you the example why.
So I managed a lot of people over a lot
of years and I will tell you that every
year,
almost every guy who reported to me
before bonus time would come into my
office and tell me how much they wanted
to make.
And every guy every year typically told
me more than he was in the budget for.
And so think about what happens,
right?
Jim and Mary.
Jim and Mary are both in the budget for
a bonus or a raise of five each.
Jim Comes in,
tells me he wants 10 never hear from
Mary.
I giggle to myself that Jim,
he so crazy.
You know we're never paid him 10 well,
it comes around time to put the budget
together,
give out the raises are the bonuses and
I know my hr head and I both know Jim
wants 10 wow.
You know we're not going to pay him 10
you know his office door was closed the
other day and the guys on the street are
looking for someone like Jim.
And by the way,
he made a really good point.
I totally forgot about the project he
did.
We'll pay him seven now how much does
Mary make?
The answer usually is five.
The right answer of course is three
because car,
just because Jim asked for more and I
choose to give him more,
doesn't mean my bonus pool goes up.
Doesn't mean my budget goes up.
And so there is to some extent a zero
sum game.
All right ladies.
Now that I've convinced you,
how do we approach it with facts,
so much of the [inaudible] and in
advance?
So much of the advice to us,
is it sort of in the meaning in the
moment you have to start planting those
seeds?
Well,
before,
first of all,
you need to know how much you should be
making and go to a payscale.com or get
raised are comparable he or higher to
any of these services that are popping
up.
Talk to your friends.
Have two glasses of wine or four.
You don't have the conversations.
Um,
so know how much you should make.
Have the conversation and advanced with
your boss about what are,
if possible,
the metrics,
how many new clean,
you know,
quantify to the extent you can.
How many new reports,
how many,
what kind of client satisfaction score,
how many new clients,
what in sales,
how many clean audits,
whatever it is you can quantify.
What does success look like?
So set that up for this is success for
me,
for the department,
for the company.
Here's what I need to achieve this year.
Here's what I want to make bright,
get an agreement.
And then the negotiation at the end of
year is not a negotiation,
you know,
to the extent,
of course,
then you come in,
you've done that or haven't done it.
Never take,
never have one.
Ask and take no for an answer that if
you're told no on the res or even if
you're told yes,
come in with 12 other request.
Right.
I want,
you know,
to take a coding class at the company
pays for,
I want to have a stint in marketing.
I want to work overseas for a period of
time.
I want to be mentored by Xyz.
I want to work on this big project.
I wanna,
I wanna I wanna and if by number 20 you
know,
typically your boss is going to say yes
to something that can turn into
professional advancement or money down
the road.
And if he or she says no to all 20 I
think you've gotten a pretty clear
message there as well.